how would you describe the leanne rhymes
of
20 years ago oh my gosh i was such a
little kid i was 17.
i was 17 dancing on a bar um you know
they
it was so uh i was kept to this like
really
innocent little girl you know from the
time i started out so that movie
and that movie was kind of like my my
innocence gone
like here's leanne dancing in a bar and
some sexy clothes um
i was just saying earlier to someone
that i was you know i was i was really
kind of emulating everything that was
going on
um everything that was around me because
i was still coming into my own as a
woman i was so awkward still
like trying to figure myself out and
then i watch it now and i'm like man
that hair flick was good i had some
moves down like i was faking that really
well
yeah no i was uh i was definitely i was
definitely still discovering
who i was you know at that time yeah
what do you remember about um that day
of that shoot
like having to go up on there and and
actually singing the song that you know
your voice was in the movie yep but
it was you at the end kind of
essentially doing a duet with yourself
with myself yeah yeah basically
yeah i they actually had finished
filming the movie like
i think two or three months before we
shot that in scene and
i ended up getting thrown into the music
like at the very last minute and then
they wanted to refilm the end of the
movie with me in it so
they brought everyone back together for
a day of filming and everyone was
everyone was incredible so many kind of
people
that worked on that film and you could
tell everybody just had a great time
doing it so everybody was
really happy to be able to come back
together for one last one last hurrah
and i got to be i got to be implanted in
you know really did feel like then the
set was so incredible it really did feel
like we were
in a bar like that you know the
it felt like one of those old school
like new york
like gritty bars so it wasn't it wasn't
hard to get into character because you
really felt like you were right there
in one of those bars it's rare that a
movie gets to become like
just part of pop culture the way that
coyote ugly has why do you think it's
essentially stood the test of time
oh wow i don't know there's something
really sweet and innocent about that
film
and uh you know obviously there's
tons of um tons of sex in that movie but
it's also there's something really
innocent about the
the girl who you know as piper's
character and
you know this is it's a sweet
coming-of-age kind of love story and
um there's great music great music
involved in that and i think the
combination of the two
like really solidified it in people's
minds and hearts and
there was a lot of um a lot of young
women that wanted to be
one of those girls i mean i think uh you
know and that that
that doesn't change i think you know we
i feel like for myself you know being 17
and
that was kind of like i kind of wanted
that that
sexuality that piece of me to kind of be
able to
to express and i think as we grow like
women who were my age that
are now you know um now my age at 38
like
we just have grown into that piece of
ourselves even more so we don't grow out
of like wanting to watch that be like
yeah like i would totally feel myself in
that in that role so
um there's i think that's part of it is
there was just so many people who
who grew up and and grew into more of
themselves and that piece of themselves
um and it reminds them of of you know
very nostalgic time in their life i
think all the good old days at the
early 2000s and and um you know like i
said there was great music involved and
i think
with the two of those mixed togethers
just kind of solidified and passed down
to generations there's so many women
that are my age that have
you know young kids that they've had now
love this film and love the music and
just one of those that can stand the
test of time yeah
and i mean you're all over the legacy of
this thing like i remember the the
marketing for the
uh soundtrack was like four new songs
right let's
rhymes right like totally and and i've
got
uh can't fight the moonlight stuck in my
head like i've had it stuck in my head
all day because i went back to revisit
the music
i'm like this song still slaps like and
it was everywhere
it was what was it like creating music
with diane warren
diane and i worked together for many
many years i love her and
you know we how do i live was our first
hit together when i was 14
and then we just kind of grew
relationship from there
and worked very closely together i
called her
uh because i wanted a song that was
attached to this film but i didn't know
it was attached when i called she had
played it for me before
please remember and she played it for me
and i called her i said i want to put
this on my record and she goes well now
it's attached to this film called coyote
ugly
and would you be up for maybe doing one
of the songs for the film i mean no one
ever gets to do four songs for a film
unless it's your film
really um you know you think of the
bodyguard but that's like
or you know purple rain but there's not
like there's not
many artists that really get to do like
all the songs for a film that
that's not theirs um so when they asked
me to do all four songs i was like
okay sure that would be great um and
the music was great like there wasn't a
song that i didn't love um
so yeah diane and i have a great
relationship and and one that has lasted
uh
from decades now so yeah she's fantastic
so what is the idea of doing this whole
mega mix
kind a re mix reintroduction of these
songs come from
well i know this music was so iconic and
and very much in people's hearts so i
mean i see it every time
people come to the show and uh when i
used to do shows but
back in back nine months ago um
but yeah when people come out they
really like you can see how much
you know people get up and jam out to
this and how much it just exists within
their
their spirit and their souls and i i
love that and
and for being able you know to have to
now have coyote ugly
20th anniversary this year um we wanted
to do a little celebratory uh
remix and dave all day who i've had a
few
um number one dance mixes with we've we
paired together for this and
made one mega mix which is all four
songs that all kind of
go in and out of each other and we'll um
that comes out uh on friday and
uh then all four of the songs in its
entirety will be releasing
all through october and into november so
um yeah people follow me on socials
because that's where you'll see
everything as they get released you'll
get to hear them in its entirety so
uh yeah i just really really wanted to
celebrate the
uh you know how iconic this music is and
and the film is
and it's a great sound like a great way
to uh you know reimagine
this music i imagine in the before times
like you said nine months ago
you would have been performing you would
have been performing these songs a lot
you know yeah can't fight the milan i
imagine was just would tear the house
down and people
yeah is there any point in time where
you're like okay guys like enough
like i've i've seen this all the time
can you can i just sing something else
for you
no i mean yeah there's there's
definitely songs that people have to
hear and can't fight the moonlight is
one of them i don't think i could ever
walk off stage without doing that song
um we were just starting to add in right
kind of wrong
um you know and it's fun because i've i
read i have reimagined these songs
for my myself and my show because
there's so many people come to the shows
and they've heard the
original version and it's fun to be able
to play and give them something new so
and then also i was 17 so like you know
i always
the versions were specifically done for
the film
um and so now it's fun to kind of take
them and
say you know how would i do this now as
a 38 year old woman as an artist like
how would these sound so
we were doing right kind of wrong in the
show recently and it's really like it's
slowed down
and it's like super sexy and it's it's
like one of those songs you want to put
on it like 10 o'clock at night in the
bedroom like it's
it's a good one so um yeah so it's been
fun to play with them and you know
that's a thing about a great song you
can kind of paint them in so many
different ways and
so you know the the mega mixes
definitely got a lot of attitude like
they didn't have attitude before but
this is even
a different attitude yeah are your boys
aware of the legacy of this movie like
have they seen
mom as a 17 year old up on the bar
dancing and singing
i don't know if they have that's a good
question i'm sure they've seen a clip of
it here or there
um yeah but we never really talk about
it too much
you know we're just like i'm just a step
mom and
they kind of every once in a while my
the youngest like
he's 13 and you know he'll come out and
watch you know some of the shows and
he's like
kind of amazed at how i do the thing
that i do in front of so many people
um it's cute to see them kind of take it
in every once in a while but yeah
other than that i'm just that annoying
stepmom who wakes them up
you know early and too early in the
morning for to go to school so
like wait ten more minutes